good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i'm proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021 2022
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences in the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
we'll enjoy presentations on fridays from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities and
hurdles which are associated with ai applications
in the biomedical sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville virginia
in june of this year applications for the
biomedical data science innovation lab program are
still being accepted until january 31st of this
month and so if you are interested in this topic
please consider applying and we encourage your
junior colleagues to do also uh we look forward
to reviewing these application materials it is my
honor and privilege today to welcome our speaker
dr claudia perlich who works for two sigma claudia
has worked as an adjunct professor teaching data
mining in the masters of business administration
program at the new york university stern
school of business where she researched her
received her phd in information systems in 2004.
she previously has worked at distillery where
she served as chief data scientist from 2010
to 2017 and also as a research staff member
in the data analytics research group at the ibm
watson research center from 2004 to 2010. there
she led teams which competed successfully in kdd
data mining competitions designed and executed
wallet and opportunity estimation models for ibm
sales using quantile regression and worked on blog
and twitter data analytics all sorts of things in
continuing our 2021 2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme claudia's lecture today is
entitled the secret lives of predictive models
in the context of ai in general and learning
predictive models in particular predictability
is usually considered a very good thing to
have that is often the goal build the model
that has the highest predictive performance
indeed the rise of big data has in fact been
vastly improved by our ability to predict human
behavior thanks to the introduction of more
informative features however as claudia is going
to describe for us in practice things are a little
uh not quite what they seem and she is going to
share some practical lessons about when models had
surprising secret life and did something very
different from what they were expected to do
she will remind us that as creators of machine
learning solutions it is our responsibility to
pay attention to the often subtle symptoms of
of these uh challenges and to let our human
intuition be the gatekeeper deciding when our
models are ready to be released into the wild
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you are watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are strongly
encouraged to submit any questions for claudia
via the chat feature in their zoom sessions and
i will synthesize these questions and ask them
on their behalf during the last 10 minutes or
so of the lecture and with that welcome claudia
we thank you so much for doing this for us and
we cannot wait to hear what you have to tell us
thank you so much uh for the introduction jack
and it's a great privilege to be invited uh to
speak here so um you know a lot about me already
so i wanted to um jump in having been um working
on uh predictive modeling pretty much all of my
life um i had some reflections uh one day when
i uh for the first time uh watched a show called
person of interest not sure if you come across it
basically the premise there is an
all-knowing ai somewhere underneath here
that can predict with absolute
certainty which person will die um
a violent death in the next 24 hours and aside
from enjoying kind of the uh dynamics of it
on the other hand it gets me really upset when
i see this in in the media because it creates
this expectation that models can be perfect um
and so as a result of this i've been pondering
for a while now um well how good can models
actually be and uh what do we need to understand
about how good models can be um so i want to
frame this as the question of how predictable
is a predictive modeling task and i
want to make it clear that this is
a function of the problem you're trying to solve
in addition to the data and the algorithm you're
using um and so in my mental mind i have the
spectrum that there is stuff that's really hard
to do um that's kind of where my day job is today
so we know um that there are tasks where you can
barely perform better than random and that's for
instance true in protecting stock market returns
efficient market hypothesis basically says you
shouldn't be able to do that at least not very
well and then on the other end of the spectrum um
you see a lot of problems uh where we have made
great strides with the uh rays of deep learning
things like is this a cat um this is inherently
a much more deterministic problem i'm not saying
it's easy to do but any three-year-old is a lot
better at telling whether this is a cat than your
wealthiest financial advisor at picking stocks
so in this kind of framework um my
last 20 years i've pretty much operated
in this weird middle ground of human stuff
and some of it could be medical but a lot
of it is also about our behavior and what i found
interesting that even with regard to how we behave
even how predictable there's a lot of nuance um so
on one hand side there have been studies based on
facebook data are showing that there's a lot about
us that is predictable if you just see a lot of
a lot of the things that we do and examples here
are religious affiliations of sexual orientation
on the other hand i have no idea what i will have
for dinner uh depends how hungry my son is when
he comes from school and how urgent it is that i
go and grab a pizza so things about my day-to-day
fall also into this spectrum and i like this
mental framework because it will be important in
understanding some of the secret life that models
have depending on where they are operating in
this spectrum so let's actually get into this
and uh dive a little bit deeper into a simple
problem here where right now all i'm trying to
predict is gender so i have a large set of people
and i actually got data from a public facebook
data set where i'm going to try to just build a
ai machine learning whatever you want
to call it to predict whether or not
this anonymized person is likely male in
this data set so we have about 200 000 people
um and you see the anonymization on top and
there's a column that indicates the gender
in addition to this i have a lot of
their activity and it's again super
anonymized so what you see on the right is
basically a sequence for each of these ids
we see things that they liked so the column on the
right is basically hashed ids of articles pictures
comments that they have liked in the past so with
this was the code set up for a little experiment
i'm going to use my favorite uh model here that's
a logistic regression but i don't think it matters
um to try to build models to predict gender okay
so take one what do you think is going to happen
if the only feature i'm going to use is the
age of the person how well do you think you
can predict gender if the only thing
you know about a person is their age
so let's take a look at a model that is really
pretty clueless um the overall accuracy is
60 which shouldn't surprise you if you
observe that the base rate here of males is 40
so if you only predict female then you have a 60
accuracy the second measure that i'm reporting
here is what's called the auc which is quite
commonly used in evaluating ranking models so
it tells you the probability that the model
will assign a higher predicted probability
to a true male person over a female and the auc
typically has a range between 50 to 100 where
100 is perfect and 50 is clueless so a little
bit better than clueless but yeah not very much
the important part is not so much the summary
statistic but it's to understand what the
distribution of the predicted probabilities
actually looks like and here is now on a holdout
the distribution of the predictions and you would
see that they are nicely centered or on point four
if i'm trying to be statistical
i'd say looks vaguely normal
um with a mean slightly above point
four and we see a little bit of a spread
now many applications that i've worked on you
don't really care about all predictions especially
when you work in advertising or even in financial
industry of picking stocks you truly believe in
do you really care about are those uh
predictions that are at the outside like at
the tail end highest or the lowest let's
take a look at what the highest predictions
are here so in the top one percent if i
rank it by probability of being male it
actually turns out my model is not as bad as i
thought um i'm getting an accuracy here of 75
that's decent not overwhelming but all
right now let's try this again and this time
i'm going to add a lot more features
so not more examples but i'm
adding additional engine to the exact same
column exact same examples i already had so
now i'm adding all of the information
about what people actually liked
and it should be as no surprise that the
expectation here is that you can do a lot better
right so you should see much better performance
accuracy is up to 83 not great honestly i had
hoped for more um but what's really important is
this very different picture of the distribution of
the predictions this is a model that is very
opinionated it knows that it knows something
so you see these two sides where you have
a lot of probabilities very close to one
very close to zero and then you still have
a little bit if you look at only the highest
predictions no surprise here they're all male so
we got this one perfect if we really only clear
the top 1 now if i have a live audience i then
tend to ask there's something here that should
catch your attention so what is going
on with those folks right there in the
middle where the model is still highly
unconvinced what the correct gender is
um and the answer is these are all the
people just didn't like anything so um
basically it's a subpopulation where
a lot less information is available
and that will be come back
and be relevant in a moment
so why did i show you this i think it's important
to understand and to develop an intuition for this
progression that you see in the distribution
of moral predictions as the predictability
of a problem increases so initially
looked kind of normal 75 correct and the
upper one percentile if you start adding the
10 most commonly liked things so it's not the
most predictive but just the most common
things that people like your performance
in the top one percent goes up and you start
to see that distribution widening a little bit
and this trend continues now i'm adding a hundred
features a thousand ten thousand and finally all
one hundred thousand things that people could have
liked and now you see this clear spikiness on the
left and the right for a for a problem where
you have a very high level of predictability
now while this is nice in this little example
in facebook why is that relevant uh in practice
and to maybe what you do my experience is most
problems most data sets have a mixture of things
some parts of it behave more like the
financial industry with very low predictability
and then other parts of it have a lot more
of that almost deterministic behavior now
what's going to happen to your model
if you have these kind of mixtures
and i'm going to now pivot um to um my day
job through 2010 to 17 when i work monthly
in advertising we built large-scale automated
systems that build hundreds if not thousands of
predictive models every day that would basically
try to forecast which customer might be interested
in which product uh might be interested in
clicking on something so we had this whole
collection of models that all predicted something
else somewhere for luxury cars otherwise for pizza
and what we observed tracking these that
there was a period in 2012 when the median
lift across many of these totally different
models increased by about a factor of two now
i have a hard understanding why people all
of a sudden should become more predictable
we have a certain level of free will i hope and so
what could cause this increase in predictability
across many different problems so we spent some
time um looking at this because while it's great
to report to your boss that hey you increased the
predictability or the performance of your models i
knew i hadn't really done anything um and what we
found were these odd websites like women's health
space but seem to have some semi-relevant
information about health for women but that
also indicated that whoever came to this website
then had a very high probability to sign up
for a to book a hotel room order
pizza sign up for new credit card
should interest in microsoft
office software and luxury cars
we spent more time on this and found a bunch more
urls that seem to be very predictive for many
different things and if you look at this i would
be surprised is if any of you has ever seen one
of those websites so what's going on here and as
a first attempt at understanding this we started
to look at the overlap between the populations of
people who go to these websites so to give you a
sense of the analysis we are trying to create this
graph where we are looking at the overlap between
populations that show up on two different websites
and we will create links whenever that exceeds 50
if you want to know why i have
this data ping me on linkedin
and i'll share more about the dark
sides of the advertising world so
to give here's a and it has a 55 overlap of
its users with youtube 28 with weather.com
and you see kind of ranked by the number
of percentage of common users it going down
so if i had an audience i would ask you to
guess what it is um i'll give you a second
to think about it um it's not google
and it's also not facebook it turns out
um that it's the new york times and if you look
back at it it kind of makes sense there's a lot
uh new york stuff and also new stuff going on so
that's kind of understandable um let's look at a
different example so here's a website where
96 of its visitors also go to film annex 93
to fog.net and you see a whole bunch more of
these weirdly predictive websites showing up so
anyone wants to guess what that is
well it's hip hop havoc of course
what's going on here something really
odd if you put this into the larger context
of the entire internet um you're starting to
see um an interesting collection of structures
so this is a visualization that we did
only including websites with enough traffic
that are connected and to give you sense let's
look at one of the smaller structures here
and this is the boston herald with a lot of
related websites or technically integrated
websites so i think that makes sense that this
is human behavior of people who are interested
or innocent but let's go back to our center here
this real clump right there in the middle um
and so this is actually where our friend with
his health base live and there's a whole bunch of
weird other stuff around it so you see this dense
connectivity of things that really have nothing to
do with each other so as far as i'm concerned
there's no way that this is human behavior
so what you're seeing here maybe not surprising
um is basically the digital footprint of a
bot network that was created take off of
defrauding the online advertising industry
so all of these websites don't really get real
people visiting them but they are showing a lot
of apps and they are being paid a lot of money for
showing ads to bots okay if all i told you so far
that there are bots on the internet um who cares i
mean that's not surprising but what has this to do
at all with my problem or not problem that
my models get a lot better all of a sudden
so what happened in this time period is
that the type of fraud had changed and
that the fraudster had discovered a really
cool mechanism of making a lot more money
and that was called cookie stuffing so if you own
a bogus website like women's health base and you
hire some dude to write your bot to visit your
broker's website so you can basically sell ads
to that bot um you will get a lot more money if
prior to coming to your website that bot goes
and visits a whole bunch of famous brands that
spend a lot of money on digital advertising
because now these are all what's
called retargeting opportunities
uh advertising a lot of money typically follow
you around with that one pair of shoes that you
looked up three weeks ago that you continuously
see popping up in your browser no matter where you
go that's called retargeting and there's a lot of
money in it now while it's annoying for the user
it creates a huge problem for me because
these bots now take exactly the actions
that i'm trying to predict so my target variable
now um is also populated by the activity of bots
who is who uh we did an analysis where we
looked for different of these advertising
relevant conversion events and so the winner
here is so to speak um the clorox video campaign
where we see about close to 70 of all of the
video completion is actually done by bots
i mean only bots are patient enough to
sit through all of these clorox videos
but you see the scale of the problem that you have
this activity called poisoning my target variable
now what i'm essentially pointing out here
is that you have exactly this scenario of
mixed population i'm trying to build a
model where some proportion or people
doing people things and then some proportion
are bots doing bad things um and so that ratio
grew from initially five percent i
think in 15 we observed 36 percent
there's a lot better bot detection today but i
think it still hoovers roughly in that area but
what's important here is that when it comes
to the question of how predictable this is
people are random robots are programmed
to do this they are programmed to go and
sit through the clorox video and as a
result if i have this mixed population
in my training examples i get this weird scenario
where all of the predicted probabilities for
people are somewhere in the middle where the model
isn't quite sure and then all of the extremes
the very large or high probabilities are purely
bots so even if the distribution initially wasn't
my target point will only try to show ads to bots
which is arguably not particularly productive
so that's an example where we spend
a lot of time trying to understand
what the hell our model was doing
and eventually we implemented a
bot detection algorithm that removed them
from the training data and my performance
went performance went to hell but for
once that was actually a good thing
quick comment if you care what about clicks exact
same problem clicks have uh similarly this um
property where part of it is human behavior
intentional interest in products and other ones
happen at random except that they don't happen
at random their accidents so it could be because
you're not paying attention it could be because
the lighting is bad so we see a lot of very strong
click activity irrespective of the product um
in specific apps many of which are flashlights
where people are stumbling around in the dark and
accidentally click on ads and again you have the
issue here clicks typical than the intentional
ones and so most of the targeting ends up
hunting for accidental clicks whereas the people
who might in fact be interested in your product
um will not be reached by the targeting
because the model kind of navigates
inherently towards wherever the signal might be
let's look at an interesting counter
example um and its implications so basically
i told any online conversion events so from an
advertising perspective where does it leave you
well things that are hard to fake or do
by accident is going to a car dealership
um so what we try to do we try to identify
people who have a high probability to show up
at a mercedes-benz car dealership now now i have
to come a little bit cleaner around the data that
we actually have um so at distillery we basically
collected um online activity across this so you
have your web activity on your laptop um but you
also see activity on your mobile devices on the
right side and if you have your gps switched
on i also get information about your location
and where you're currently hanging out all of
that gets connected through your home ip address
so i can now um use your web activity and try
to predict a build a classification model to
identify who would show up at a car dealership now
there are a couple of issues with that first off
um it's the location data available in
attack is not particularly clean and will
comment on data quality in medical areas in a
moment um a second area problem is that i may
not get the connection to your laptop right so for
instance if you sit at a starbucks um then your
browsing history is totally different or maybe
your neighbor hacked into your wi-fi and while you
have been to the car dealership um i'm actually
observing the browsing activity of your neighbor
um but let's assume assume that works out somewhat
what i'm going to do now is i'm using the urls
that people visited as features in a model to
predict whether or not they go to a car dealership
now i touched on this um and i'll give you a bit
of a flavor of issues with location information
where what we are observing in terms
of the location that people are in as
highly problematic so you
see artifacts for instance
about 30 percent of users of smartphones seem to
be travel faster than the speed of sound every day
um clearly there's something not quite right
um the other thing that you're observing
is so called people stacks so you see locations
within the u.s it's actually cornfield in kansas
where at any moment in time there are about 100
000 people sitting right on top at the exact same
gps um and the reason is that's the geographic
center point of the us and a lot of gps systems
if they don't want to tell me where you are then
they only tell me that you're in the u.s and
then somebody replaces that information with
the uh central point of the us as the latter
another thing that you see is this pattern here
if you squint at this graph on the right you see
this odd stripping there's a little bit of other
stuff going on but you see these horizontal lines
and these vaguely slanted vertical ones and
that's basically a rounding error so when you
round the lat long that's when you get these
artifacts people aren't exactly at this place
but the machine interprets it as location
zero zero in the rounding and therefore
would seem to be so i gave you a lot of good
reason to not trust my target variable because
i don't know for sure whether or not you actually
we're at that car dealership or maybe just in the
coffee shop across the street so what that
means for our prediction task we have really
three different populations in here so we have
people who are indeed at the car dealership
so where the one in my target is correct
and they're correctly associated history
then i have people people who wear the car
dealership car dealership so that's a kind of
a false label as positive and then you have people
who may or may not have been at the car dealership
but i have the wrong features associated with them
because say your neighbor hacked into your wi-fi
what's going to happen if i
now going to train a model
on this scenario so here's the model and what
you see on the right are the parameters of a
logistic aggression where it's ranked so
you see on top those urls where people who
have this predictive probability up at that
mercedes-benz car dealership and it's actually
surprisingly good um let's look maybe into a
little bit more detail so there's a lot of car
stuff going on i mean there's mercedes there is a
bunch of other car related you see other uh brands
of cars that people might be considering
so that's actually quite quite surprising
you also see real estate so there is this old myth
uh that i thought was a myth in um an advertising
that people who also buy um real estate and those
of you who recently in during covert moved out
into a slightly more rural area would certainly
testify that yup if you buy a house outside of
the city you need a car so we see evidence of
the model picking up on this um i also see some
upscale fitness well it's mercedes-benz so you
can imagine what type of person buys a expensive
car and signs up for a very expensive fitness
center in any case this is interesting in the cell
that of those three populations the ones who
actually went to the car dealership and i had
the correct history on where the signal is and
all the other stuff the people where i had the
wrong location information or the wrong history
receive very low predictions because they are near
random the model can't find any signal so in fact
my model almost acts like a low-pass filter where
my predictions may in fact be more correct
than the labels i had on my training data
because it only focuses on what quote has
information and makes sense so in this case
it actually worked very much in my favor that
the model so much focuses on where the signal is
um there's a little experiment that i did
uh where i was really curious to uh to see
well how bad can my random labeling b before
my model falls apart so i'm going to take
this data set again that you can download
if you want to reproduce it um and so
um well it's still predicting who's mail but
i will start to randomly reassign labels so
for these rows i may randomly pick the opposite
or the same and train my model and on the test
set i retain the original labels and i want
to see how bad can my disturbance get before
the model falls apart and what to me what's
fascinating is you could mess with almost 50
of the labels before you see a significant
decrease in the accuracy in the top 1 prediction
not talking about oval accuracy
but if i'm only looking at the
highest prediction i still get a vast majority
of correctly identified males and here you
see how that model kind of gets clearly more
uncertain about what the hell might be going on
so it's kind of wider but you still still see
these spikes at the end um for the sub-population
where the data made sense and it was more
predictable um so since this worked so well um
my final example for advertising i promise we'll
move to uh medical applications in a moment
um one of the things advertisers love um
the group of people are frequent travelers
a they probably have a drop that pays enough so
they have enough income to buy a whole bunch of
things they might also be bored sitting around
waiting for their flight um and therefore have
time to look at ads and they may even have a
bad conscience being away from the family for
so long so they might want to buy gifts so great
audience to target what do we want how do we find
frequent travels and since it worked so well
the last time let's this time predict who will
show up at jfk so we're now going to build a
model similar to the one for the car dealership
but this time we're predicting who will go
to jfk and here's the model same as before
i rank the most predictive urls that
indicate that somebody will show up at jfk
i'll give you a second to
peruse this interesting list
all right so let's let's do a bit
of a deep dive let's start with
um some religious content often um in spanish
um the plot thickens um there is trump seed news
flight attendant resources um and then finally a
bunch of sports stuff so i don't think that what
we found here was the elusive frequent traffic
law with management but what the model
basically figured out who has to be at the
airport the people who work there the flight
attendants the baggage handlers all of those
so the people i'm targeting here are
really just people who work at the airport
um there's a really deep implication of that
regard to biases that i will get back to uh
towards the end as i'm opening this up more for
discussion but i did promise to touch on stuff
related to medical applications so i have tinkered
with medical applications um a couple of times i
volunteered to help with a readmission prediction
for a rehabilitation hospital called berkey
um here in westchester and so they were
interested to see if there is evidence that you
can find with ai um whether rehabilitation indeed
improves the outcome for the client the patient
as well as the hospital by reducing the
probability of readmission so we got very detailed
patient data including medical records diagnosis
medications as well as information about the most
recent hospital stay and we set it up as a model
to predict the probability of readmission and
the model had a lot of a lot more information
but i will show you just the component that was
relevant to uh to berkey where we're only looking
at the parameters on this logistic model for
different post hospital care models so these
codes here pso6 through ps65 they're basically
capturing what happened to the patient sent
home sent in a nursing home went to rehab
and the parameter estimate is the impact of this
action on the probability of being readmitted
in particular this is the rehabilitation treatment
so ps62 means the patient was transferred to rehab
and good news in some ways um we actually see
that it seems to have a decreasing impact on the
probability of readmission and this model actually
controls for a whole bunch of risk factors that i
just didn't include here but there should be
one thing you really want to know more about
there should be one particular case that you
want to understand better at the very bottom
pier 65 seems to have a huge increase probability
and readmission so who are the people or what
happened to them that seem to suggest that
they have an extremely high readmission rate
and it turns out what this
code is meant to capture
is that the pace now
that should be very predictive of readmission
but not the way it looks um in particular
um what we're seeing right now is if the
patient passes away then the probability
of readmission should be zero but what
we see is an increase in the probability
and it turns out what happened in this
case was um something that had been
basically part of the pre-processing
when the data was created for me
based on whoever had access to
the transaction level data set
they basically just for the target variable
they defined readmission of having a subsequent
event at a hospital in less than 30 days
so readmission is anybody who has anything
within 30 days of leaving the hospital so
they basically just put a filter saying if
the time to the next admission is less than
30 in less than 30 days that's a readmission
but people who passed away this time to the
next event should be infinity except that
whoever was running the database didn't
know how to put an infinity and instead
coded people who never came back to
hospital with zero days to the next event
so meaning everybody who passed away automatically
was labeled as three admission and everybody who
was actually super healthy and never came back was
also coded as a readmission so um this is a huge
problem and basically means the data is entirely
unusable for what we're setting out to do um there
is the fundamental problem that you should include
in the model whether or not somebody passed away
explicitly even if it happened after um being
sent home because obviously those people wouldn't
be readmitted um and that's a different case um
but we still can't really tell apart whether not
coming back without knowing that somebody passed
away but that's either a good or a bad sign of
health so you get these very model information in
the severity of the case if both very healthy and
dead people end up having the same label so the
point i'm making here is data errors are a hell of
a lot easier to predict than uh readmission um and
if you think that this is a rare case um there is
a lot going on wrong with especially clinical data
and patient records and having very close control
and understanding of your data collection is
incredibly important another example in a similar
vein that is a lot more subtle but arguably
with as big implications um is a task where
we were trying to predict well identify breast
cancer based on our fmri images so we were given
sub-regions in images that were
featurized so you had 117 numeric features
representing a region in an fmri image and
it was labeled and we were trying to identify
the probability that this candidate region was
indeed malignant we worked on this that was
actually in the context of a competition and the
data had been originated and donated by siemens
and so we turned we came up with a really great
model so it did incredibly well we had a very
nice increase in performance in terms of this
true positive rate relative to the false positive
rate per image um and so the equivalent of an auc
here is something like 93 percent um and we also
were very good at identifying people who were with
high probability healthy meaning had not a single
uh candidate region with a probability
or a large probability of cancer so
about sixty percent of the cases we were
very confident we could identify ourselves
so um looked great all good um except at some
point and that was more accidental than anything
else we observed some weird um behavior uh when we
started looking at the model predictions vis-a-vis
the patient id now the patient id technically
should be a random number assigned by the
hospital to the patient and it's not the thing
you would add to a predictive model to identify
whether or not somebody has breast cancer um it
turned out if you just look at the graph here
on the x-axis is the log of the patient id and
you see these very clear groups right so there
are a bunch of people below twenty thousand
there are some in the middle between a hundred
and five hundred thousand and then there are
a lot of patients with above four million
which you know it's okay the problem is the
patient id is exceedingly predictive so you
see in the lower group your incident
rate is high with about 36 percent
in the middle group you only have about one
percent and then in the outer on the large side
you have some people with 85 percent
without even looking at the image i
can tell you the probability of cancer is
85 percent um and some where i can also
say the certainty probability of cancer is zero
what's the story and what does that mean um
there's a good question whether or not you
really shouldn't use the patient id for your
model because what it really does it proxies
for the location of the fmi machine clearly
the provider of the data siemens had given us data
that originated from multiple different locations
and presumably because these are rare machines
some of them were treatment centers and others
were just screening centers now from a medical
perspective it's important to know whether or not
that image originated in a treatment center
because your prior on it being malignant is
very high so in some ways this is what the moodle
should do but what it really means that the model
has accidentally picked up basically the
average grayscale because even without
giving the model the patient id it would still
learn primarily the location effect and what you
end up with the model is really it predicted
where the location was and the calibration
of the machine that was used to collect your
data and actually learn how to detect cancer
so what's the big picture here there are a couple
of uh lessons that i hope you can carry over in
your future applications of machine learning
um in in medical application um i think the one
that to me was most eye-opening is
that models can in fact create biases
and the underlying driver of this is this inherent
predictability of different subpopulations
and this is in addition to biases that you may
have in your data set explicitly so here for
instance in the training the travelers outnumber
employees by about 15 to 1. but when you look
at only the highest predictions the employees
outnumber the travelers by a factor of ten to one
so you cannot rely on the fact that your
predictions will mirror the basic distribution
of your training data overall um and so
to to really demonstrate this i went back
to that data set from facebook um where now
i'm not predicting gender but i'm predicting
something else in particular i pick certain
likes that have even interest by men and women
so i pick a thing that men and women liked and
now i build a model based on the other features
to see who would be liking this one thing that
i picked as my target variable um so we pick
something and now we build a logistic regression
that predicts that and what i'm interested to see
is what happens to the gender distribution and
here's an example of what we're seeing where
if you look at a decreasing sword so with the
highest probability of liking the thing in the top
1 of predictions there were exactly zero females
whatever this thing is the most predictable group
are males and in that part of your prediction
you only had males and then over time you see
as you kind of went down with your cutoff
and looked at larger ranges of predictions
you ended up having more male to female ratio
but this has huge implications on things like
drop recommendations where you're worried about
not getting enough female applicants even if you
balance the data set beforehand you may still
end up with all of your highest recommendations
being one gender or the other it's not always
detrimental to females it's just whatever is
more predictable that's what the model will
end up recommending you so what are some of the
takeaways um leading into the questions i think
my general rule is you have to know your data
there's no way around it and i actually
dislike it when my data sets are prepared
by somebody else i find in the medical
domain it's often hard to really understand
how the data was collected and
pre-processed but it's incredibly
important to to see that the second piece of
advice i have it is always very interesting
to really deeply understand what these most
extreme predictions are either the highest
or the lowest probability and deliberately
hunt for distortions there my third point is
a lot of people talk about de-biasing alongside
with model transparency but if you think about my
breast cancer model there is nothing in the model
that would tell you that there is this problem
of it really having only learned the grayscale
b being able to identify this as the root cause
it really comes from the underlying data and so i
think transparency is good and you saw this in the
advertising models but it is not sufficient
the same way that de-biasing your data set
isn't sufficient because your model can
create biases by itself and that means that
we have to take ownership at the prediction
and action level to test for biases and to
correct them at them we cannot rely on
the various mechanisms that have been
uh proposed to would force models to be unbiased
i don't think they fully race to the rise to the
occasion and so my general attitude is rather than
forcing models to be de-biased i'm more interested
if for instance you wanna to invite an equal
number of male and female into your interview
process to basically do so and just have the
model give you the top female and top male rather
than trying to somehow get it to be perfectly
unbiased which i don't believe is necessarily
possible so thank you very much um i think we have
the questions collected if there are any i want to
close by i would love for folks to reach out to
me on linkedin um write a sentence or two about
um having seen me here um so i don't dismiss you
with with other folks um but yeah i would love to
get to know some some of you um given that we have
to do all of this via zoom here thank you claudia
thank you so much i'd like to remind our uh any of
our participants who are joining us here on zoom
to send in any questions they have for claudia um
in the zoom chat and while we're waiting for that
to happen uh claudia that was fascinating and we
touched on so many things i think have affected
almost every one of us in some way
or another certainly with our online
browsing behaviors you know which this is just a
personal thing that just happened with with me and
my family is we just had this big snowstorm many
of us were affected here on the east coast by this
and uh we lost our power at my home for a number
of days and um my wife was uh kind of actively
trying to figure out how we could heat food
and water and keep ourselves warm and so she
did some searches for some like propane stove type
things right and uh did a few searches for those
well of course the internet has figured out that
she and i live it's the same ip address yeah so
now my uh my my websites are filled
with advertisements for camping gear
this family must really like camping and so
i'm getting all sorts of things and there's
a weird side effect for whatever reason people
who like camping must also like dua lipa the uh
uh kind of uh songstress du jour uh at the moment
and so i get all sorts of of advertising for uh
her recent pop albums or where she has shown up
on a red carpet and i don't know what that's about
but nevertheless i find that the context is also
something that i think is misplaced sometimes when
one is like trolling through say search results
or responses to particular questionnaires or
what have you about what motivated the person
to respond in a particular way and we tend to
take that as sort of this black and white thing we
provide provide labels for things without any sort
of question sometimes about whether or not that
label is appropriate or not we build these models
and find that they actually misclassify things
a lot too or inappropriately classifying things
you know people who are basically in survival
mode trying to keep from freezing to death to
people who like recreational camping i i'm
sure that you see this all the time yes i do
i mean i i basically decided that i i needed to
make a career move to get out of advertising i
tend to somehow say um i've gotten too cynical
for advertising so that's why i moved into finance
that's right now it's it's also interesting that
you found um a with your mri data because that
is that's a the area in which i'm uh uh for do my
research so i do human neuroimaging related work
um organizations such as the national institutes
of health here in the united states some various
other european entities have undertaken major
programs to try to map the human brain um through
a collaborative multi-site based approach so they
marshal multi multiple institutions from around
say the united states to all gather data using in
principle the same scanner and the same protocol
and hopefully the same subjects and to gather that
data and pool all that data so that no one center
is responsible for all the data collection we're
getting a national kind of representative sample
etc but what we find is that the results are
often dominated by site-to-site differences based
upon if the scanning was done in essay and at nyu
versus the university of virginia versus ucla the
university of washington whatever it is there
seems to be these enormous variations and one
may not appreciate that and it's interesting
even though the scanner has been standardized
you're supposed to use a siemens 3t scanner that's
not that's the same probe doesn't matter it does
not seem to matter it doesn't no it will find that
the only answer i have found to work is you almost
have to explicitly let the model control for
it by telling it exactly what this thing is so
adding interaction effects to capture kind of let
the model absorb the information from the site
and then look at the uh residual information uh
from there that works better can you really model
out all of these good confounders i'm not sure
but it's a minimum to tell me that they existed
and often the when you're trying to think about
privacy preserving they don't want you to know
that because it becomes a privacy issue and
then you're losing the one tool you need to
fix a lot of these problems yeah and you know
certainly from a modeling all of those interaction
effects may soak up so much of your variance
that you're left with nothing you know and
even if you did have something left you may not
have degrees of freedom for example to be able to
associate it with anything meaningful one of the
other things that um one of our listeners today
has brought up is um in clinical data one of the
real challenges we often have is missingness in
the data where either an entire subject will have
like partial record or rather their data can't be
trusted and you have to kind of code it as missing
and then kind of adjust what recommendations do
you have for dealing with missingness um
especially if it's random or deterministic
um i mean i have never really found missingness
to be random um so i i don't rely i don't
like to rely on assertions of statistical
assertions you get by assuming randomness
i always assume it's not missing at random and um
i actually wrote a quora answer on on this whole
thing um so what are your options uh imputation i
would strongly recommend against it i think that's
a bad idea in academia people just like to delete
rows which in industry you can't afford because
there's this one instance where you have missing
stuff you need to make predictions so now what
right so i think it might be easier for to
do but it's not the right answer um i think
indicator variables are the only way forward um
so basically add an indicator variable for it
and then um you can impute it with whatever you
want at that point uh whether you want to make
interaction effects for the indicator i found
indicator variables of missingness incredibly
predictive repeatedly um the quote there
is a more sophisticated way that i've seen
where you basically build a model for each
possible combination of available features
and then you just pick the one that's right there
was some work by mithal zartzky from ut austin
uh looking into this that's computationally a
little bit challenging but might indeed from um
from a quote clean modeling or information usage
perspective um be the best way to go forward
so that's kind of yeah you can do separate
models for different levels of missingness
you can do um basically induct indicators
alongside with imputation all the other
options i consider uh subpar now most of the
audience for this lecture series are going to
be in the biomedical domain are there any lessons
that you learned while being in uh in the business
world that might have any sort of translative
power i mean i think the large lesson of um
being as closely or as velvet in the data
collection process as humanly possible um and
doing most of your code data
pre-processing or empty features
yourself that might be a privacy concern but i
feel like uh i have to be part of that and the
closer the collaboration the better i think with
the brookie example that was very much at arm's
length and i think it could have been better
better um if we had worked more closely um
and and so i like to build simple models that
i can go and dissect for data problems like
logistic aggression um i know how to look at
these things and have expectations and then
kind of dig into it in any stuff that doesn't make
sense to me so i even if the ultimate performance
is much worse than a more sophisticated xg boost
or deep learning i like to start with something
that i can at least probe for oddities
in the data that i don't see otherwise
i think that's very sensible advice and being able
to take your models apart i really appreciated
how you did that in your uh in several of your
examples where you're just not taking these as
sensible predictors is only when you kind of like
start to peel away the onion skin that you realize
that oh of course it's the it's the people who
work at the airport who need to go to the airport
i didn't see that coming but yeah yeah supposed
to don't make that perfect sense right but you
know a lot of maybe in some instances a lot of
people might not have appreciated that nuance
and they're you know now their model may be very
highly accurate but it's entirely misplaced like
selling you camping gear when you don't really
want it right anyway claudia thank you so much
for sharing your your very very wise and
uh sensible recommendations with us giving
us some great examples of great things to think
about thank you so much we really appreciate that
thank you to everybody who's out there um and
with that uh we'll kind of close things down
uh dude batten down your own personal hatches for
the next uh winter onslaught that's coming and in